[Music]
the year is 2100 and humanity is living
in a solar pump future of free energy
and perfectly clear air we've managed to
stop the rising global temperatures and
stabilize our atmosphere so yeah life is
pretty dang good now
or is this just
fantasy
the year is 2100 and the air is so hot
and toxic we can't go outside once in a
century weather events happen daily and
we can't even remember the last time we
saw another person in real life
or at least that's what might happen see
right now the year is 2021 and the
recent u.n climate change report
outlines what our futures might actually
look like depending on what we do right
now we as a society are still addicted
to fossil fuels for our energy but what
if we weren't what if instead we got all
of our energy from the sun
how many solar panels could power the
world 23 billion solar panels that is
how many we will need
and that's good all right great job
let's get it up
yeah
good job okay yeah thanks that was
really easy so good thing that was a
really simple answer to a really simple
question
when i started writing this video three
years ago i had no idea how complex this
question was going to be to answer turns
out energy is really complicated and
just simply taking how much energy we
use and figuring out how many panels
could supply that power is not only
wrong it's meaningless there's a lot of
weird misconceptions around how energy
works and so in this video i'm going to
try to clear that up because i realize
this one is going to be a little too
important to just gloss over
so let's get into it
solar power is cool and all but like why
do we need it in the first place the
core problem is just that we were
releasing too many greenhouse gases into
the atmosphere which is warming up our
planet too much if burning fossil fuels
didn't do that we wouldn't be having
this problem
it is a little ironic though because
greenhouse gases are actually why
complex life exists on this planet at
all really yeah yeah without carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere the planet's
temperature would be negative 18 degrees
celsius and that's like way too cold to
support life
yeah carbon dioxide is like a blanket
for space rocks because it captures the
heat from the sun allowing us to survive
in the cold dark of space although add
too many blankets and it starts getting
too hot that's basically what we're
doing right now and that's why there's
such a huge push for clean energy but
humanity is power hungry
can clean energy match that appetite in
2017 the total world energy supply was
162 quadrillion watt hours and i know i
know big numbers like that they don't
mean anything they're just too big for
us to comprehend but that's all of the
energy humanity uses in a year which is
around the same amount of energy that
hits the earth from the sun
every single
hour that's crazy it makes sense because
the sun is literally just a giant fusion
power plant that's a million times
bigger than our entire planet it's
basically an endless energy source
fossil fuels on the other hand are not
renewable by definition there's a finite
supply so we could run out in theory
even if that might take a while yeah i
mean we literally thought we were
starting to run out of oil like a while
ago turns out we figured out how to
actually squeeze all of the oil out of
the rock around us and suddenly america
became one of the world's top oil
providers
it's amazing what society can accomplish
with the right economic incentives
so how much non-renewable energy do we
have left well it's hard to estimate
since we don't know what we haven't yet
found but it's believed that there's a
quadrillion kilograms of coal still
underground and if we could extract it
all right here it would form a chunk of
coal the size of an asteroid we are
definitely on the naughty list because
this is how much coal we've burned so
far meaning we could literally continue
burning this without slowing down for
over a century but we dig up other stuff
too such as natural gas petroleum and
uranium because nuclear energy is still
technically non-renewable and has to
deal with geopolitics just like fossil
fuels this is the total energy from all
of those underground resources compared
to the energy of coal rather than
showing their physical sizes which
wouldn't be as useful however all of
this becomes negligible in the face of
solar energy it is so much more
plentiful than anything we can ever dig
up and this this is just for one year
what about next year or the year after
that or the year after that or the year
okay you get the point until the sun
dies its energy will always be here free
for the taking that being said solar
panels still require a lot of land to
produce meaningful amounts of power
but how much land are we talking about
this is a square meter and the amount of
sunlight that is hitting just this
square is called the solar constant
and uh let's uh just get rid of all this
other light real quick
that's better you see once you account
for atmospheric absorption around a
kilowatt of power actually makes it to
the ground and that's enough power to
actually run a pretty high-end gaming pc
however the amount of actual power that
you can use depends on things like the
weather or the time of day these panels
for instance actually rotate to follow
the sun giving them an extra two hours
of usable sunlight per day if you can
see the sun you can harvest that energy
using photovoltaic solar cells the
little squares of silicon that you see
inside of an actual solar panel and
these things when hit by sunlight their
electrons get really excited and that
excitement creates an electric current
that we can then use to power things
it's like harnessing the happiness of a
child when you give them ice cream
so there are lots of different kinds of
panels but for the sake of this video
let's use an average commercial panel
which is one meter wide and two meters
tall it's got 96 solar cells with an
efficiency of 20
so yeah it's not the best panel out
there but you know what this thing puts
out 400 watts of power under ideal
conditions the cool thing about solar
panels is that they're easy to scale up
if you want more power just add more if
you want 4 000 watts of power you just
need 10 of these things and that's
enough to power a small house and if you
want a million watts or a megawatt you
need 2500 panels
but how many could power a city los
angeles county consumed 68 terawatt
hours of electricity in 2017 while also
receiving five peak hours of sunlight
per day to provide that energy la would
need almost a hundred million of these
panels that will take up a lot of space
72 square miles actually but that's just
a square eight and a half miles wide and
it can be any shape you want there's a
huge amount of empty desert land just
outside of la which could easily be the
home to all of these panels i'm sure the
hippies living out there wouldn't mind
hippies
we're not hippies we're libertarians
but what if there is a more obvious and
reasonable place to put the solar panels
say somewhere you'd like to have some
shade maybe where you want to park your
car
in a parking lot
average cars spend about 95 of their
entire lives literally just sitting
around la is infamous for having a lot
of cars and therefore a lot of parking
lots in fact the city has about 19
million parking spaces which is 200
square miles of land dedicated just for
parking which is just stupid by the way
everyone should just get an e-bike or
a one-wheel come on are you surprised of
course i was going to say that anyway
this is easily enough area to power the
entire county of los angeles from
lancaster to long beach
parking lots plus at least our cars
would be a lot cooler in the shade you
wouldn't have to blast the ac so hard
so let's scale that up to fit the entire
united states we used around three and a
half thousand terawatt hours of
electrical energy in 2020 so how much
land would be required to power that
a lot certainly but perhaps not as much
as you might expect a typical solar farm
requires about four acres of land for
every megawatt of electricity it
generates so america's solar farm would
cover eight million acres that would be
like adding a little solar hat to the
top of texas the only state with a
one-star review over the course of five
hours this relatively small patch of
land could generate all of the country's
electricity for the entire day but where
does that stack up against how we
currently use our land well 10 million
acres have been carved away for coal 26
million acres have been leased to the
oil and gas industries and 22 million
acres of land is dedicated to producing
the ethanol that goes into gasoline we
make that from growing corn so what if
we just paid those corn farmers to put
up solar panels instead listen i'm just
saying oh oh here is a stat that
completely blew my mind do you have any
idea how much land in america is
dedicated to cows
41
of all of the land in the country is
just for raising cows or to grow the
food
to feed cows
almost half so forgive me if i don't
exactly see land as a restricting issue
against solar panels
yeah but if you're astute you may have
noticed a major problem with this entire
idea and that's the fact that solar
panels only work when they're getting
hit by the sun what about when it's
nighttime
i mean we still use energy when it's
dark out just because the sun's not
there doesn't mean we can't still use it
the short answer is that we store it in
batteries however before we start
talking about energy storage i think we
need to understand something even more
complex what is energy
it's easy to confuse energy with power
but they're very different things think
of it like the difference between a
vehicle and speed you know energy is a
thing but power is the speed at which
that thing moves energy takes many
different forms but generally when
people think of energy they're you know
thinking of their lights air
conditioning refrigerator computer
electricity but electricity is just one
form of energy and it's not even the
most common do you know what is
heat
fossil fuels like coal oil and natural
gas are forms of chemical energy they
need to be burned in order to be useful
and that's an important distinction
because that conversion to heat is
costly
you see heat is really low quality
energy it's inefficient and easy to
waste but electricity on the other hand
is like primo high quality top shelf
energy because it's very efficient and
surprisingly hard to waste okay so how
much of our energy is actually electric
not much around 20 of all of the energy
we actually use is electric wait what
yeah no i can explain this better here
this gnarly looking image is called a
senki diagram and it breaks down
america's total annual energy use in a
really cool way over here on the left we
can see the energy sources but as we
move to the right we see where they end
up and the thickness of each path
visually indicates how much energy flows
there which is pretty cool but if you
look over here at the right of the
diagram you'll find something
interesting this is all of the energy we
actually use but you see the box labeled
rejected energy
that is the energy we waste when
converting chemical energy to heat
that's right two-thirds of the energy we
actually generate is literally wasted
because we dale and hate
we always hear that we need to
transition to renewable energy but what
that really means is that we've got to
upgrade everything to be electric right
now 80 of our energy is not even
compatible with renewables because it's
not electric if it was we'd actually
generate far less energy overall because
there wouldn't be any of that waste or
at least as much of it because remember
electricity is the good stuff
okay so we gotta electrify everything
but where do we start i think we can
start with machines and i'm talking
about like engines that burn fuel to
move they can be replaced with electric
motors there are over a billion
passenger cars on the road today there's
also trucks planes trains ships tractors
whatever the heck this thing is just
make them all electric
okay obviously that's easier said than
done and probably going to be very
expensive but what is the value of our
future and seriously just that alone
will go so far towards making a cleaner
future there are of course so many
things we need to do to reduce our
carbon footprint but which fossil fuel
has the biggest shoot okay here is
another stinky diagram showing energy's
carbon footprint these are all the
emissions we want to stop and right away
we can see that the two biggest
defenders are petroleum and coal
natural gas is at least cleaner than
both of them even though you know it's
still bad but coal is what annoys me
because basically the only thing it's
used for is to generate electricity and
okay sure about 10 percent is used to
make steel and important stuff like that
but coal can be replaced entirely with
renewable energy right now all right so
we need renewable electricity that we
can store the concept of a battery is
not limited to what we commonly
associate with the word i don't care
what the dictionary says a battery is
just a thing that stores energy trees
are chemical batteries lava it's a
thermal battery being up high is a
gravity battery anything in motion is a
kinetic battery the whole idea behind
regenerative braking in cars is to
capture the energy of its motion which
slows down the car and so you can
literally recharge an electric car by
just going down a hill normally that
kinetic energy is injected into the
brakes as you guessed it heat
speaking of charging electric cars
couldn't we recharge them by attaching
solar panels to the roof and i mean yeah
actually that's a good idea
but let's take a closer look this might
look a little ridiculous but if the car
is just gonna sit there all day in the
sun it could make a lot of sense
especially if you don't drive much the
problem is that you'd be lucky to get
three miles of range added every hour on
a perfect day and that would take weeks
to fill up your car what about the dream
of driving entirely from solar power
well dream on this tesla draws about 15
kilowatts of power while driving so this
is a 15 kilowatt solar array okay
obviously this is unrealistic for a
number of reasons but it really shows
the irony of solar power there's so much
of it around us and yet cars they just
can't get enough there's a good reason
why the solar cars that actually do
exist look like this this is why we use
batteries they act as the buffer zone
between electrical generation and use
can you imagine if every time you wanted
to drink water you had to drink directly
from a hose instead of filling a glass
like a normal person
that is like trying to use renewable
energy without energy storage the
lithium ion battery is an incredible
invention i am also admittedly a huge
lithium-ion nerd it's powerful portable
efficient and arguably the enabling
factor behind most of today's technology
but what if there's a better battery one
that is so easy to access and so
plentiful that not only does it cover
most of our planets it's the most common
element in the entire universe
hydrogen
water is created when oxygen combines
with hydrogen and the raw fuel to make
hydrogen is simply water the energy from
this one jug of water is about the same
amount as what's inside the battery of
this tesla in fact our oceans could
store enough energy to power society for
30 million years sounds pretty great
right well today it can't even be
considered a good battery hydrogen is
very inefficient it's expensive and is
still mostly produced by burning fossil
fuels even though you can literally make
hydrogen by electrocuting water it
requires a lot of energy to separate the
water molecules into hydrogen and oxygen
but
in the future that might not actually
matter if renewables are so plentiful
that it becomes something like free
wi-fi then any amount of energy would be
okay
of course this is all still hypothetical
there's a lot of innovation that needs
to happen before energy storage and
renewables can truly be effective in
society so maybe now you can see how
meaningless the prompt to this entire
video actually is how many solar panels
could power the world i think a better
question might actually be what would it
look like if our electric future was
powered by the sun there are dozens of
different technologies that harness
solar energy outside of las vegas is a
really neat thermal power plant that
concentrates the sun's energy by using
thousands of mirrors and they all
reflect light to the center
of that of that tower that you can see
i'm gonna switch cameras this allows it
to basically act like a regular power
plant except it's solar i mean if you
think about it even the wind is solar
powered because the heat from the sun
causes the wind but i digress my
original idea for this video was to show
that we could power the world by
covering new zealand and solar panels
middle-earth could be our
salvation in place of a dark lord you
would have a solar panel however the
truth is that we need that many panels
always pointing at the sun so the land
we'd actually need is closer to the size
of france the point is that there is
more than enough land to go around for
this but that leads to the question
where would we put them
everywhere why not pretty much anywhere
there's empty land that can see the sun
locally to you can have solar panels and
probably be enough to power your entire
town which is pretty cool the future of
energy is going to be very local
there's just one last problem
how do we do that
easy all we got to do is just
we just need to um
cut cut that's a wrap everyone yeah
i mean that's all you need we have the
crew for like another hour i mean nah
it's fine we don't need to answer that i
mean what's the point of any of this
like why do we need to worry about it
code rent for humanity human activities
are responsible for climate change we're
already paying the price of ignoring
scientists warnings a hotter future is
already locked in the extremes we're now
experiencing fires floods droughts and
storms will only intensify we don't
think we've had co2 levels this high for
about five million years this is the
last chance climate change is here now
but we are also here now and if we don't
act
who will
climate change is real it is
unequivocally human-caused and we've
only just begun to see its catastrophic
effects
it's easy to point out how it might be
too hard or too expensive it's easy to
look at other massive problems and say
what about them
it's easy to be angry
it's hard to be constructive
so this is the part of the video where
i'm supposed to start telling you what
you can do to help
but i think i'll start by just letting
hank green give you some advice one of
the most important things that anyone
can do and anyone can actually do this
one is to be informed on the different
policies and laws that governments
create to try and solve these problems
my goal for this video was to try to get
us on the same page about the potential
of solar energy and electricity simply
put however we get there that's the
direction we gotta go so hopefully we
can all agree on that but now i have a
message for the young people watching if
you want to help shape your future
consider becoming an engineer because
engineers are like superheroes who have
powers like solving hard problems and
building a better future for us all you
see we need more engineers and
engineering needs you
i know you didn't do anything to deserve
this whole situation and that sucks you
probably wish none of this had ever
happened
but whenever i'm feeling this way i like
to remember my favorite quote so do all
who live to see such times but that is
not for them to decide
all you have to decide
is what to do with the time that is
given to you
thanks for watching
hey ren
oh hey
i'm sorry he's putting a spell on me i
am very sleep deprived i hope you
enjoyed the video i got kind of real
there well you might be interested in
something a little bit more fantasy
based say our new dnd show son of a
dungeon it's a dungeons and dragons show
like you've never seen before see we
love playing d d but the problem has
always been like how do we visualize it
with son of a dungeon we are doing a lot
of photogrammetry we're shooting on a
green screen with virtual productions we
are putting you in the game with us as
the characters we got myself nico jake
and dee the four of us going on a
fantasy adventure through the
wonderlands of dungeons and dragons this
show is 12 months in the making there
are eight episodes and each one's about
an hour long this is like a full season
of television but it's d
the first of eight episodes is going to
be available right here on the corridor
crew youtube channel with weekly
releases happening on the website
corridordigital.com all subscriptions
come with a free two week trial but
listen all of that money goes into
producing high-end content like son of a
dungeon you get cheaper merch extended
react episodes you get exclusive content
it is thanks to the subscribers on the
website that this series got made it was
literally funded by you so stay tuned
because the first episode drops in a
couple days right here on the corridor
crew youtube channel for free and weekly
episodes dropping on the website after
that so if you enjoyed this solar panel
video consider subscribing to our
website it actually is a big reason why
this whole solar panel video exists at
all thank you for watching
you